Oh
yeah well they're triad of behaviors
that are the earmarks of autism include
difficulty in social interactions delay
in the development of speech and
communication and those are
distinguishable and repetitive behaviors
almost obsessive like behaviors the
recognition of this triad as a condition
that we call autism began only in the
late 30s and as the diagnostic criteria
began to be more widely applied more and
more children were being called autistic
and the definition I think I mean people
now talk about autism spectrum disorders
where a child is it has varying degrees
of these abnormalities it is not in fact
an extremely well-defined disorder it
has sloppy boundaries to normal behavior
we all know people that are awkward
socially there are many people who learn
language late in life and we may all may
know people that's that that have
stutters or have obsessive behaviors or
even hand-wringing so there is something
of a continuum in all three of these
things that's not a condition whose
boundaries are well defined yet if you
meet a child with autism you can
generally say that this there's
something profoundly profoundly wrong
here but it's a it's a hard disorder to
define better than that and probably the
reason it's harder harder to find it
better than that
is that the number of genes involved the
number of underlying causes that can
create this triad is very great for
example
the syndrome itself is enormous ly
varied and if you have listened to
somebody who studies autistic children
children with autism you'll frequently
hear them say that each child that they
see is different than the next it's not
really a syndrome in the way that Down
syndrome is a syndrome there are a
variety of genetic disorders that are
frequently you could almost tell that
the children who have these disorders
have the same underlying cause because
they'll actually look like it's not just
Down syndrome that has that property
progeria has that property there are a
number of childhood disorders where the
children that have these disorders
actually look alike that's not the case
in autism each child has sort of
wonderfully different than the next
child so there's a huge amount of
variability and I think this is this has
confounded the general public because it
appears that the rate of autism has been
going up so dramatically in fact I think
that's mainly due to increased diagnosis